[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored with
me Richard Tice and Isabelle oakshot on
an extraordinary day of unbelievable
Bombshells from Prince Harry The
Sensational claim he says he killed 25
Taliban fighters and thought of him just
as chess pieces we'll speak to the
former British army colonel who says his
comments are truly a betrayal of the
military
Prince William physically attacked him
after an argument over Megan alleges
Harry will speak to Princess Diana's
friend and psychic Sally Morgan about
where the reconciliation can ever be on
the cards
and the revelations don't stop there
we'll get all the reaction to Prince
Harry admitting to taking cocaine when
he was just 17 and also literally
begging his father not to marry Camilla
fearing she'd become the wicked
stepmother
live from London this is here's Morgan
uncensored with Richard Tice and Isabel
oakshops
well good evening as everybody knows
this show is called Piers Morgan
uncensored for a good reason Piers is a
champion of freedom of speech he doesn't
believe in censoring or canceling anyone
indeed the Piers Morgan show has a
special line in uncanceling people but
while the cat's away the mice will play
so the four Piers comes back Richard and
I want to make the case for a single
Global exception to his policy on
canceling people in the sorry Case of
Henry Charles Albert David mountbatten
Windsor AKA Prince Harry we think his
behavior has been so appalling that he
must with deep regret and after careful
consideration be both censored and
canceled
following his latest extraordinary
attack on the royal family accusing
Prince William of physically assaulting
him to the point that he was left with
Telltale bruises and suggesting that he
might shun his own father's coronation
surely at his high time to no platform
the world's most famous Ginger Winger to
stop listening to his increasingly
hysterical never-ending list of woe's me
grievances to stop indulging his bitter
Vendetta against his brother our future
king and stop rewarding his woke
snivelings with multi-million pound
publishing and film contracts and
frankly absurd interviews
unbelievable Harry's allegations against
his own family have already caused
massive hurts huge damage to those he
claims to love and to his own country a
country he once proudly served and was
once willing to put his life on the line
for
he fought bravely against fellow service
men and women in some of the most
hostile territory in the world how come
how is it possible that he's now become
such a wimp he's bleeding about
stumbling on a dog bowl
his book spare which obviously really
should have been called spare us and his
endless self-pitying interviews only
make it harder and harder to achieve
what he says he really wants which is a
reconciliation with his brother and his
father his attacks on them and on the
Princess of Wales are cowardly because
he knows they cannot and will not
respond
perhaps it's now time for the rest of us
for the rest of the country to speak out
on their behalf so our proposal from the
end of tonight's show after these
exclusive Revelations coming up in the
next hour is a clear and compelling case
yes for Prince Harry to become the first
person on Piers Morgan uncensored to be
both censored and canceled
as of next week when peers is back
just call him by his first name Henry
and one of his many many spare names
David
in a Flash
troubled miserable Prince Harry will
become plain old Henry David able to
live the quiet Anonymous life
he says he craves for
we hope this is one cancellation appears
might just possibly consider
well the last two hours it's been
revealed that Prince Harry lost his
virginity in a field behind a pub to an
older woman who treated him like quote a
young stallion the other revelations in
his book include admitting he killed 25
people during his second tour of
Afghanistan Harry described the human
beings as quote chess pieces that had
been taken off the board the Duke of
Sussex also admitted he took cocaine
when he was just 17. he also accused
Prince William of physically attacking
him in a heated argument over his wife
Megan Harry said his brother called
Megan difficult rude and abrasive the
Princess of Wales isn't spared either
Harry recounts an argument in 2018 where
Megan said Kate had a quote baby brain a
month after she gave birth to Prince
Louis he also turns a knife on Camilla
the brothers allegedly asked their
father not to remarry over fears she
would become their wicked stepmother and
in the latest extract of his interviews
to be screened in the UK in the U.S
Harry goes even further
I don't know how staying silent is ever
going to make things better wouldn't
your brother say to you Harry how could
you do this to me after everything after
everything we went through wouldn't that
be what he would say you probably say
all sorts of different things if you're
invited to the coronation will you come
there's a lot that can happen between
now and then but you know the door is
always open the board is in their Court
do you still believe in the monarchy yes
do you believe you'll play a part in its
future I don't know the quote in his
book where you refer to your brother as
your beloved brother and arch nemesis
strong words what did you mean by that
there is always been
this competition
between us weirdly I think it really
plays into always played by the air
spare
wow well joining us are the Royal
correspondent for Vanity Fair Katie
Nichol and the sun's Royal editor Matt
Wilkinson who I think has been whizzing
through an entire copy of the book is
that right Matt
there's a Spanish version yeah I had a
enormous pleasure of reading the book oh
well you don't sound as if it was yeah
tell us what you found no it was it's a
it's an incredible book and I think
you've gone through some of the main
headlines here today but I don't think
I've ever read a royal book of so many
Revelations and the most important thing
here is there's so many Revelations from
a member of the royal family and I think
that's what the issue is here there are
as Katie will tell you there are many
many raw books she's written some
herself but there are many many raw
books but the problem here is that a
beloved member of the family like a
treasured brother of William a son of
Charles he's the one that is actually
airing all this dirty linen this is the
problem that the royal family are facing
because there's all sorts of stories all
sorts of Revelations that come out about
the royal family the problem is is that
the senior member of the royal family is
actually making these accusations but
also revealing the private lives the
private conversations
um situations with Kate and William that
would normally be behind closed doors or
normally that journalists would not be
allowed to report on or if we tried to
report on them we would told it was too
private but let's say we have a you know
a brother of William and the son of
childhood is actually making these
things public and I think that's the
most aggravating elements of this I mean
there is
there are extraordinary things from this
book what is a single story if you like
that jumps out at you the most that left
you with a jaw dropping I can certainly
tell you what mine my take on it is but
I'd love to hear from you
well the ones I think it's about Harry's
life it's about his drug taking and the
losing the losing his virginity I mean
these are things that members of the
royal family don't normally talk about
you know he's talking about talking
about his time in the Army Afghanistan
where he was saying that he killed 25 uh
people of the Taliban but it's this
opening up of his personal life about
the sort of tale about him losing his
virginity behind a pub and about his
cocaine taking and his he's opening up
elements about where he was
hallucinating and talking to a bin I
mean these are ruined deeply deeply
personal stories from from you know from
from Prince Harry just unbelievable Matt
I mean Katie Where Do We Begin how how
shocked are you by these Revelations I
think after the um after the sort of the
Netflix documentary you sort of thought
what else is to come out I think I said
that didn't I now I'm feeling really
silly because I I didn't think that he
was going to go anywhere near where he's
gone I mean I I completely agree with
what Matt's just said I mean I I've done
this job now for nearly 17 years I'm you
know he's not the first member of the
royal family to write a book but he is
certainly the only member of the royal
family to have written a book this
explosive I mean those Bombshells just
come thick and fast and I think
we've almost become oversaturated by
Harry and Megan and this narrative
there's just so much of it but actually
if you try and just forget the docu
series if you try and put that Oprah
interview to aside you just come into
this book
the idea that a senior member with royal
family would write a book like this I
mean I would say is Unthinkable you you
really have to stop and think I cannot
believe what I really particularly by
the way Isabel the account of him losing
his virginity unless that's a dodgy
Spanish translation I am astonished it
is jaw-dropping there's like it is in
there that I'm not even sure we will not
repeat for a family program I mean look
you and I sort of generally have a
pretty dim view of talking about Harry
and Megan the whole time but we both
agreed that this show can only be all
about Harry and Megan for tonight only
because it is utterly Sensational isn't
it it really is I mean the Oprah
interview was was jaw-dropping but that
did focus on a sort of a a short a short
period this man's his entire life and I
think for me having written biographies
about him and spanning those early years
it is you raised the question Katie
about
what's believable and is this all
believable I mean there are serious
questions about what Megan said in the
Winfrey interview so
how much of this really is believable or
is some of it just exaggerated unlike
Matt I've not had the privilege yet of
reading the entire book um I mean one
inconsistency that jumped out
immediately was Harry saying that after
he'd been allegedly shoved to the ground
and had this physical fisticuffs with
his brother his first call was to his
therapist well my first call would
probably be to my other half but the
fact is the other half had said she
wasn't allowed to see a therapist
because it wasn't a good look for the
royal family it didn't it wasn't but but
actually how does that Harry has a
therapist on speed dial yeah and so I'm
sure we will pick over the narrative and
there will be discrepancies and I
suppose we ought to point out the
obvious which is this is one person's
side of the story there are always two
sides to the story but unfortunately
we're not going to get to hear the other
side of Charles's narrative or Williams
because they're not going to go yeah
let's just come back to Matt because he
has read the whole thing
um I have two quick questions on that we
haven't heard much so far about what
Harry has to say about the queen and any
conversations that he had with her and
so I wonder if you could tell us a bit
about that and also can you just
elaborate on that bin story you told us
about just now you referred to Harry
hallucinating talking to a bin I think
we need to know more of that
yeah we'll be hopefully putting more in
the paper very shortly but there is a
there is there are scenes or there are
scenes that he has written about about
taking some drugs while at Eaton and it
goes into quite a lot of detail about
hallucinating
um with some friends
um wrong spliffs and talking to a to a a
bin that talks back to him and it's like
opening up a kind of scene as a teenager
and addressing the kind of
I mean he
he I mean he's supposed to be fair to
her he has always been publicly he's
always been very respectful about the
queen and it is he's very respectful
about the queen in the book
um you'll be seeing later that he he
does talk about his trip to say goodbye
to the queen as in he he talks about his
trip where he went to Balmoral there's
an epilogue that I think you might be
aware of that he'd written the book uh
over the summer he'd been signed it had
gone but he's written an epilogue
um talking about when he learned that
the queen had died the conversations
that he had with with the King and
flying up without Megan and then saying
a personal goodbye to his grandmother
and that's quite touching
um I mean again it's a very personal
story that he's revealing a lot of
detail about the moments that he had
with the queen with the queen about
moral but you're right he's
he's not gone in much detail on
Revelations about the queen because I
don't really think that's that's
tasteful there might not be any but
there is there are scenes where he is
talking in his epilogue about about well
I can't wait to hear all the detail in
the paper tomorrow thank you very much
Matthew and um Richard I mean Where Do
We Begin what was in his mind when he
thought that it was right to reveal
these extraordinary details did he think
that in the modern world it's good to
reveal details about your drug taking
and your virginity because you saw one
of the things that struck me is where he
says in one of his televised interviews
and we've seen the clips of them
um I don't think anything can be
improved by me keeping quiet I mean just
how stupid is he I mean Katie how thick
is Prince Harry sorry to ask him well he
didn't do terribly well in his a levels
I mean we we know that we didn't go on
to University and he went into Sandhurst
um but
I I don't know there's a lot of people
will be thinking he is incredibly
deluded to to have done this I mean the
idea that he says in in one sentence
that the door is open for a potential
return I'm assuming for a Reconciliation
that he he believes in the future of the
monarchy is so incongruous with what
he's doing and the impact of his words
and what the impact of those words is
having on the monarchy it's almost like
he is just deluded and lost in his own
world we'll have to talk about what's he
trying to achieve with all of this I
think apart from earning a load of cash
well I mean clearly that he's gone for
the big bucks I mean that is
indisputable and you're not going to get
35 million dollars
worth they certainly have but I think I
think there was a genuine desire for him
to tell his own narrative to tell I mean
I I was told many years his truth his
and Megan's truth but I do think he has
felt unheard for a very long time and
just just to play Devil's Advocate just
slightly here I that idea of being
despair is something he has struggled
with for a long time I have met Harry on
many occasions he said to me before in
the past you know I just I want a normal
life I want to get on the tube I want to
go and be able to buy a coffee I want to
be able to do this he wanted everything
that he didn't have that wasn't within
his Birthright and I'm afraid he has
wanted all of the Privileges of being
Royal and none of the responsibilities
and the underlying sentiment in all of
this I do not see him take
responsibility for anything this is it I
mean he literally wants to have his cake
and eat it at all times yes including
wanting to be in the royal family and
out of the royal family making money
whilst representing the queen it wasn't
going to work he's tried to create this
third way I I don't believe it has
worked Katie you're going to stick
around thank you very much indeed for
that well next tonight Prince Harry says
he didn't think of 25 Taliban fighters
as people but instead just chest pieces
that is taken off the board we'll talk
to Military and Security Experts about
whether his comments how have actually
increased the security threats to him
and the whole of the Royal Family
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
still ahead tonight what would Princess
Diana make of Harry's bombshell
allegations about William attacking him
we're going to ask Princess Diana's
friend and psychic Sally Morgan shortly
but next uh Prince Harry has had a
decorated career in the British military
determined to serve in not one but two
tours of Afghanistan against the advice
of the UK government the security
services he helped to save countless
lives as an Apache helicopter pilot but
after admitting he killed 25 Taliban
fighters during the heat of the battle
describe them not as people but as just
chess pieces being taken off the board
does this in some way leave a black mark
on his time in the armed forces well I'm
delighted joining us is the former
commander of the brute forces in
Afghanistan Colonel Richard Kemp and the
former head of Royal protection dye
Davis and Katie is still with us in the
studio a very good evening to you both
um Richard if we can go to you first
please these revelations in this book
about his his time in Afghanistan and
sort of treating Taliban fighters that
he killed as just sort of chess pieces
on the board that he just sort of
swatted away is that the sort of
terminology that that soldiers members
of the Armed Forces use generally or are
you surprised by that
no it's not the kind of way that British
soldiers are taught to view their enemy
uh he says that he was trained to think
of the enemy as something other than
human in in kind of woke terminology he
says that they we were taught to other
them
um which of course is not the case and
if if we were if if the British army in
Afghanistan nowhere else was taught
to treat their enemy as something other
than human beings then that would be
against the Geneva Convention because
they have to be respected at all times
obviously when you're killing them
you're not respecting them that much but
if you capture them
if you if they're wounded if you
actually kill them and the corpse is
there all of them the procedures are
laid down they have to be treated
properly uh and if you were to train
your soldiers to regard these people as
just chess pieces then how would you
then at the same time tell them they've
got to look after them they've got to
give them medical treatment they've got
to feed them when they're prisoners
they've got to give proper burials for
them well it's nonsense it sells books I
have no doubt
so Richard is that the key thing I mean
obviously you know members of the armed
forces are subject to uh Syria's uh the
rules of the battlefield the laws the
legality of it is he really just using
this terminology actually just to
increase the value and the sales of the
book in your opinion I'm sure he is
because because that what he's described
is certainly nothing like reality and
he's he's not a fool he would have
trained he was a you know an important
member of the team as you rightly said
he was a Apache pilot who saved many
soldiers lives if you're if you're a
fool you can't do that sort of thing and
so he knew exactly what was going on he
knew this wasn't the case but it's a
kind of Hollywood type thing isn't it to
say you just treat them as chess pieces
it it's got no resemblance to reality so
to be clear Richard you've you've never
heard anyone that that you've served
with use that terminology
you know quite the opposite I mean the
uh obviously you don't you don't you
don't love your enemy I mean maybe if
you're a you know a proper Christian I'm
not a very good Christian but perhaps
you do love your enemy but but no of
course of course you you don't just see
them as being sub-humans and you know
that was the the way the Nazis dealt
with their enemies but we certainly
didn't do that and and I don't think any
you know maybe the odd exception but I
don't think it's very many British
soldiers who would see their enemy in
that light and if they did they would be
disciplined for doing so they they have
to treat them well you have you have
examples of
um of British soldiers waking up badly
wounded in a field Hospital in
Afghanistan next to them is an Afghan
fighter an Afghan Insurgent who is also
being treated in the same place because
you treat them humanely and and that's
the reality the problem with this with
his approach is that he gives he's
giving ammunition now to people who are
desperate to get British soldiers and I
want I do want to talk to Guy Davies
about this
um what uh implications would you say
die that Prince Harry's uh approach on
this uh in the way that he's phrased it
talking about the Taliban as mere chess
pieces on a board what implications did
that have for his own security has he
made himself something of a Target
well I'm appalled in the same way as the
Learned Colonel is appalled I'm appalled
from a protection point of view you're
quite rightly raised the issue now that
he arguably has raised his own profile
and that of his family and his wife and
also his children I mean they live in
the United States where I worked with
the FBI in the Secret Service there
there are such a large number of far
larger number of people in the United
States who now could see this as a
potential Target even more than before
and again in this country should he ever
come back there are large numbers of
those who still support Isis and others
so yes he's done himself no favors I
have to say the word Pratt comes to mind
that's a police term for what we call
idiots but I think he's a complete and
utter Pratt and die what's extraordinary
of course is that he's been actually
complaining about the lack of security
when he's been coming over to the UK and
now what what you're saying and I think
it sort of speaks for the obvious is
that essentially he's upped the risk
he's increased his own vulnerability
well there are and there are people in
prison uh in this country who posed a
threat to him luckily the security
services and others caught them in time
but you know you only need one idiot to
hear a voice from the so-called Allah to
go or any religious feature and actually
go and say go and do your duty and
that's all it needs and yes but you know
when they came to this country they were
provided despite all this nonsense they
were provided because they were with the
royal family they chose to reject the
issue of of uh by going to America and
equally uh you will see that when they
came to Los Angeles they're going
arguably and I've worked in Los Angeles
to one of the most dangerous cities in
the world where Firearms are everywhere
so no he has raised his own profile by
his actions and you know he had security
from the day he was born to the day he
decided to go from Canada all the way to
La he knows security he knows the risks
he knows the threats and of course
there's a a court action going at the
moment well thank you for that let's
just quickly bring back Colonel
Richard's Camp
um is there any way that Harry is
suffering from some form of PTSD I mean
does this some what explain his
extraordinary Behavior clearly uh it's a
big thing to kill anybody never mind 25
insurgents 25 hostiles perhaps that's
affected her much more profoundly than
he's acknowledging
anything's possible I suppose I don't
know I mean I'm I'm not a psychologist
and um despite guy's very generous
characterization of me as being a
learned Colonel which is something I've
never been accused of before
um I I don't I just can't see into his
mind everything I can see there's so
many contradictions in this particular
part of his book uh for example he says
I would you know I was desperate to go
home and and with a clear conscience so
that I hadn't killed civilians innocent
civilians as if that's some kind of
great virtue of course it's not a it's
every single soldier feels the same I
know I've spoken to soldiers who have
accidentally killed civilians and who
regret it for the rest of their lives
I don't know his mind
um Colonel Richard Kim die Davis thank
you so much for that insight into what
appears to be a significant dramatic
increase in the security risk not only
for him and his own family but actually
potentially for the broader royal family
here in the UK yeah which is perhaps
something he hadn't even thought about
and it seemed very naive doesn't it I I
actually take a bit of a different view
to Colonel Kemp on the way he
characterized it as as pieces on a
chessboard
um that might not be the full army
training but in in the reality I think
very much you know forget the
formalities the official linger of it of
course in the heat of war in the in
theater you know you are facing a threat
to your life every day of course you're
going to think of them as other and I
wonder if we're going to hear stories
from people he's served with as to
whether actually he really did Kill 25
you know others who've uh who served
alongside him because that will be
another thing about whether or not
actually he's telling the truth here I
mean I I suspect that those he said to
us will actually have more honor than to
do that you know there is it's so
unusual to speak out in the way that he
has and I just think that members of the
Armed Forces they take great pride in
kind of protecting each other and just
not breaching the kind of protocols in
that way and and sort of you know
behaving as one would expect of of
members of the Armed Forces you say
behaving with any thoughts on that Katie
just well I interviewed several people
that Harry served with for my biography
on Harry and um actually they all said
that he was a brilliant soldier that he
was one of them and I I think it's well
you're right I I think they would they
would never dream of turning on Harry I
think they'd also be quite shocked the
idea that he has given a number to the
number of people I don't think it's a
dumb thing in the military I just don't
think it is I spent a year and a half
researching the Armed Forces talking to
all sorts of people at every level and I
never heard them talk quite like that
and you wonder why he's done that was he
persuaded by Publishers is it to make
him look like the hero Prince to America
yeah the the heroes holder who knows
well coming up next Princess Diana's
friend and psychic Sally Morgan reveals
the conversation that she had with
Prince Harry that's ended up in this
bombshell new book spur she joins us
live shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
still ahead tonight is she really the
wicked stepmother we'll discuss Prince
Harry's claims that he and William beg
their father not to marry Camilla
talking about that shortly
Among The Sensational claims in Prince
Harry's new book are allegations that
Prince William physically attacked him
Harry says he grabbed me by the collar
ripping my necklace and he knocked me to
the floor I landed up on the dog bowl
which cracked under my back the pieces
cutting into me I lay there for a moment
dazed then got to my feet and told him
get out
also in the book he details a
conversation he had with his mother's
friend and psychic Sally Morgan where he
asked about his mother's death he wrote
In the book that she told him quote
you're living the life she couldn't
you're living the life she wanted for
you
well Sally Morgan joins us now Katie is
still here and also we've got
psychologist honey Lancaster James down
the line
um Sally hello wow great to have you
with us
um what are your thoughts
dear Harry where do we start yeah I mean
well it's to me he is dear Harry I know
that you know he's taking an awful lot a
stick at the moment but it's his way of
grieving I think as well I think that
he's great I I you've got to remember I
know him or spoke to him because of his
grief and uh yeah that's I think that
it's all of this all of his behavior
it all traces back to how they were not
allowed and I'm including William here
yes they were not allowed to grieve in
the way that they wanted to for their
mother so I was fascinators to learn
that Harry contacted you and he appeared
in the conversation he had with you to
be troubled about whether or not his
mother's death was really an accident is
that correct well that was the first
thing he said to me what did he say the
first thing was hello how are you and
remembering a time that we'd been
together and then he said I really need
to know what you think about my mother's
death and I just said to him in me I was
a bit shocked
um and I thought well it's not my place
to give him my thoughts he's asking me
as a medium as a psychic and I said you
need to speak to your Aunt Sarah Sarah
mccorkindale that was Lady Diana's
sister that's right now I thought that
was incredibly interesting because this
is new to me so you advised Prince Harry
to speak to Princess Diana's sister
about what really happened because I
thought he shouldn't he needs to get he
needs to get the information from her
she was the one that said to me four
days after the funeral when she rang me
at home because I used to see her on a
regular basis at least three times a
week right she was um most of the time
the Princess of Wales lady in waiting
she would go on and so she would travel
down from Norfolk I live just off the A3
at the time she would pop into me then
pop into me on the way back to Norfolk
so and I she rang me we were very four
days after the funeral and I was really
shocked because the first thing I said
to him when I picked up the phone yeah
um what are you doing ringing me you
know your grief you're grieving and she
said oh Sally I just there's a few
things I just want to say to you and she
wanted to talk about a tape that I
because every single reading is taped
right they took the tapes yes um and
there was a tape that she was really
interested in that they had listened to
on the train yes on the way to autrop
yes and so she spoke about that and then
she said to me what do you think
happened and I said well it was an
accident wasn't it just so just to be
clear then Princess Diana's own sister
four days after the funeral was
questioning whether or not Princess
Diana's death was truly an accident well
that's right well that's how you see I'm
telling you what she said to me we can
make of it I'm not saying you're not
right but when she said to me will you
always will you promise me that you will
always say her death was an accident and
I went well it was wasn't it and she it
you know why would she say that to me
let's go to honey uh honey good evening
thanks for joining us so you've heard
these extraordinary Revelations these
bombshell claims uh from Prince Harry in
this book I mean what are your thoughts
about the State of Mind of Prince Harry
how how difficult will it be for him to
to try and seek some form of
reconciliation that he talks about given
what he's done
well the truth is I mean I wouldn't like
to comment on what his State of Mind is
at the moment he's not my client if he
was my client I have to say I wouldn't
be giving any interviews at all like
because that confidential
um but what I can say I mean certainly
the revelations of what has been printed
in this new book have been coming thick
and fast today I mean my phone has been
off the hook everybody is talking about
some of these allegations some of the
things that have been published and so I
think if we sort of reflect on those
claims
um I mean it's my specialist area to
support public figures that's the area
that I generally work in uh my company
on set welfare we work with production
companies around the world we specialize
in supporting people who live their
lives or work in the public eye and what
I see from people that we've worked with
over the years when they do a tell-all
book when they they go live to the world
with some big Revelation is often an
individual I mean we work very much with
the real life person we try to get
things from the horse's mouth and what I
often see is that there's usually been a
very long time before this big moment
this big Crescendo where it all comes
out where this person has privately
struggled to hold a lid on perhaps some
things that they've desperately wanted
to talk about that advisors have said
they shouldn't or people have said to
them that
um you know you should keep this all
behind places so that's the only I can
think really he will have known the
impact of these Revelations
um
how will he be feeling now it's going to
be all over the world's newspapers for
days and weeks I mean how were they as a
couple
how will they cope with this what would
be the impact on them
well one thing I'd like to think is that
they have support and one thing that um
Harry and Megan have been public about
is that they do have mental health
support I think Harry has talked about
that in his book as well how he has a
therapist or therapists some people
providing them with support and I really
hope that that is robust
there is a weird discrepancy though
isn't there honey in the in the book he
talks about this extraordinary Showdown
with William and which became physical
William allegedly knocked him to the
ground and the first person uh Harry
says he called was his therapist at the
same time as having previously suggested
that Megan wasn't able to get a
therapist because that wasn't the done
thing in the royal family how are we to
reconcile these two conflicting
narratives from him
well well again from my understanding
about Megan's comments about that was
that at a particular time she wanted to
go somewhere and get help she says that
she wasn't uh permitted to do that I
think that is different
um but what I think Harry's done there
is actually something that in some sense
psychologically was probably a sensible
thing to do if that's what he did
because at a time when your emotions are
running High it actually can be much
more helpful to turn to a professional
for support than to your close family
member because they are involved and
they will have feelings about it as well
and they'll be sort of too close to the
issue so in that sense I would say
anyone else out there anyone watching
actually who has been through major
sources of conflict in their own family
lives let's face it this is a very
common thing I would say it is helpful
as you say honey he is going to need and
Megan are going to need a lot of support
thank you so much honey indeed Sally
final thoughts I mean just on this
extraordinary day
um completely extraordinary I don't
think there there'll ever be a
reconciliation with the brothers I just
it's never going to happen I mean and I
think that it's so sad because one of
the things that he said to me when I had
that conversation
we spoke for a long long time he wanted
to know how his brother he said my
brother how will my breath be knowing
that William was you know the the heir
to the throne this is the tragedy of it
he's probably permanently destroyed the
closest relationship oh completely the
the pair of them had yeah and I think
any any form of reconciliation will be
literally for the public eye for just
how it looks I don't think it's going to
have any depth to it I mean I very much
respect to what honey had to say there
but I can't help feeling that too much
therapy has been part of the problem in
here you know this is a young man who's
been encouraged to share his feelings to
explore them all and actually hasn't
known the limits of keeping that within
the confines of the consultation yeah I
mean just some of the stuff frankly I
don't think most of us want to hear
there's just so much I don't want to
know about him losing his videos it's
all this sort of very personal detail
Stardust off everything is there any
prospect that actually that'll that'll
in some way endear him to me yeah no I
don't want to think no one wants to
think of him as being used like a staff
we're being a bit older I mean are you
speak for yourself
zero dear dear oh dear next tonight
Prince Harry says he's yet to decide
whether he will attend his father's
coronation but after after today's
Revelations should it even be invited
we'll discuss that next
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Buckingham Palace has kept a dignified
silence today saying nothing about the
onslaught of accusations from Prince
Harry
but for the royal family actions usually
speak louder than words so could Megan
and Harry actually be banned from King
Charles's coronation well here to
discuss this with us tonight is talk TV
contributor Paula Ron Adrienne
broadcaster and former MEP Alex Phillips
and Katie is still with us Paula to you
first good evening good evening
so what do they do do they never
complain never explain
or will they have to uh say
Recollections may vary well this teams
here
they do say they definitely do explain
and they definitely do complain what
they don't do is attribute it
specifically to them it will be a royal
Source or a source close to the family
or a source close to XY orz and we know
that that happens and we will see that
Onslaught that tsunami of them not
explaining but actually really they are
over the next couple of weeks I mean
isn't that exactly what Harry has been
complaining about he alleges that this
is what they made a habit of but this
that they repeatedly briefed against him
and is why I personally I find that
quite hard to believe particularly in
the case of William I really like to
hear what Katie thinks about that
because I just don't really see with
Will and what he had to gain from doing
that okay well there wasn't that many
things again and as far as I was
concerned I I never had a courtier
briefing against the coverage yeah of
course they breathe that's their job
they're a Communications
it was a deal between them
I mean so Alex what how do they respond
do they respond or do they maintain the
moral High Ground I don't think I mean
he's just blown himself up hasn't he
what is there to say if if they were
going to say anything at all and I don't
think they should they should probably
say are you okay you know do you need
help because what he has done is very
destructive to them but it strikes me
it's incredibly self-destructive and I
wonder where his support network is
about his support network I think he's
had too much of a support network
there's all this psycho Babble that's
got him into the messenger it seems to
me they're exploiting a very Troubled
Man well there is that there is that um
Katie how do you think Prince William uh
personally responds to this he is so
dignified you know this is a a guy who's
never put a foot wrong he is his face is
poker face all the time yeah he's he I
mean it is you're right it is um but
I've seen a sort of a trend for William
to I think just start speaking out a bit
more so he addressed those racism
allegations I mean he was doorsteps one
sentence but it was racist but it was a
really important thing he was clearly so
angry yeah that he felt the need to
respond on the back of that quite tricky
towards the Caribbean where they came in
for a lot of flack he and Kate he wanted
to address that he wanted to discuss it
no did he just no no it wasn't planned
it wasn't signed off by by Charles or
anyone else it was something he wanted
to do so I think while there is still
a generation at the palace that believed
the never complained never explained
Mantra is the best I think the Prince of
Wales is is actually perhaps
um more inclined to answer back and I
wonder if he might I think if we're
going to get a comment at all I think
it's likely do you agree with Paula
there'll be lots of sort of behind the
scenes briefings from I can tell you
we've not had we've not had briefings
today there's there there has been a no
comment they are not okay they they know
that if there are briefings that they
will only fuel this narrative
um where does this stop I mean we raise
the question of could he could they be
banned from the coronation I don't think
they'll be I personally I don't think it
was interesting to hear Sally predict
that they won't be there but I don't
think they'll be banned Sally's strong
view was that they won't turn up
certainly I'm sure they'd rather be seen
to take the initiative here rather than
be you know the humiliation of well it
might it might well be the best case but
I don't believe that they would be
banned I spoke to a source you know
close to Charles who says he wants to
extend this Olive Branch he wants
relationship with his sons
if they are invited
should they attend
well all of this is more publicity for
them which is what they want but the
problem is their publicity takes away
the publicity of the world family it
damages the Royal band and this isn't
about the Kardashians this isn't a
reality TV show this is a constitutional
monarchy this is how our country works
and is governed and so I think the world
family have no choice but to extend an
invitation but you know be it at their
own Peril because it will be all about
those two yeah and it may be that this
sort of mutual understanding is that
whilst the invitation is extended it's a
formality and it will be you might have
a different view on that absolutely not
they need to be there they should be
there really if they are not invited
let's think about them
if they're not inviting no I'm not a
softie I'm a realist and actually I'm
dealing with the hard decisions that
people have to take if they don't turn
up what are we saying what is this
family saying that's a different point
isn't it is if they're invited and let's
assume they're invited should they
attend absolutely and will they
will they that's another matter should
they attend absolutely why because Harry
says I want my family back well then
let's start getting this family back
together doesn't that just ruin the day
for everybody else frankly but this
isn't about everybody else though is it
but what about what about Camilla the
evil stepmother
I mean really how's she gonna feel but
who's surprised at that depiction
and whether they should be there I think
we should remember that they were at the
Platinum Jubilee celebrations and they
were there in a very unthustacy way and
that they didn't upstage the Royals I
mean they really played by the rule book
they were there but they were not there
at everything before all of this came
out it was although Oprah had happened I
mean do you think on this evil
stepmother thing just put that in
context he was only saying you know we
wondered if she would become this
caricature he's not saying she was I'd
like to know what he says about her and
the relationship didn't he say things
like you know she was briefing against
that you know them and beaten to the
Press herself and wanted the crown and I
mean he has just taken a you know one of
those fire blazer guns and gone after
everybody I mean I have to say and miss
all of this spare a thought for poor
kierstama the leader of the opposition
and today was his big moment wasn't it
he was going to do his big state of the
nation's speech his reset following on
from Rishi sunak's speech yesterday can
anyone remember anything that KIA said
today anyway though did he let's before
he's taking back control is he yeah
so far as it works out too well I wonder
if the king's saying the same thing I
hope he does but at least one person who
does need to take back but isn't that's
really the point I mean storm has never
really said anything of of any sort of
note or interest he's never taken a real
position so maybe actually maybe this
has helped him bless him I wonder
because it's the guardian isn't it that
leaked this in the first place the Harry
Revelations perhaps kierstama wasn't
being left wing enough for them so
they're just like
what's a bit weird is the guardian and
it was Sensational that they got hold of
this before everyone else but why didn't
they actually run it in the paper does
anybody have any inside info on that one
I mean a weird decision you've got a
massive Global scoop and you've just put
it online bit strange and for it to be
leaked however it was to a British paper
I mean we know how much Megan and Harry
hate the British press so it was whether
it was a calculated leak or not I
suppose that will emerge it's the
guardian maybe maybe they just didn't
know how to handle it you know it's the
guardian after all that is also true one
way or another I guess it works out for
them if they're if their aim is maximum
Firestorm I think
mission accomplished what a day but I
mean this is just the beginning when we
actually see the book it's Megan's book
as well isn't that oh please no and
what's the time frame for Megan's book
we don't know yet I mean she's been
threatening to do an autobiography for
for a while now so all right probably
testing the water with Harry's and
seeing where they go next oh goodness
yeah don't forget to get this as a two
book deal for Harry as well
so that's three in total and then she
might have a two book deal
they've you know killed themselves off
today I think they've completely trashed
their own bandage
of appetite for it I think well listen
thank you very much thank you Katie
thank you very much that's it from me
and Richard wherever you are up to
whatever you're up to make sure it's
uncensored good night good night
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]